WITHOUT A POINT IS FOUR GAMES.
>> JohhN.
FIRST OF ALL ON BATHERSON ANDS,T
LITTLE JUMP MAY HAVE CHANGED
FORMENTON'S MIND AS TO WHAT HE
.
>> Jon THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT IS JUST THE HOUTS IT ACROS.
HOUSER.
MAKES A SUPERB FIRST LOOK STOPS
AS HOUSER. QUICK OVER THE
SHOULDER.
CAN I STOP THE PLAY RIGHT HERE.
>> Jon::.
>> Dave: ALEX TUCH BA
BUFFALO.
>> Jon:ORSBERG.
KREBS, OF COURSE, ANOTHTH
HAYDEN TO
WATSON JUST GOT IT OUT.
STUTZLE FINDS A PASS THAT SEE IF
HE CAN CONTINUE THAT FINDLET FR.
BEARNT
ONE-ON-FOUR SORT OF INNOCENT
PLAY AND DYLAN CO
NUMBER 72 THOMAS CHABOT IS
BERNARD-DD SENATORS COMING INTO
THIS.
IT'S A STRONG PASS ACROSS, BUT
IT'S THE MOVE.
TO MAINTAIN POSSESSION. ZONE.
NICE SMART ADJUSTMENT BY OTTAWA.
CHANGE THE LOOK A LITTLE BIT.
ST FRONT FROM STUTZLE ON
>> Jon:.
LAST MINUTE OF PLAY AND BUF. MOE
SECOND PERIOD THAN THE FIRST.
34 SHOTS RIGHT NOW.
WIN THE GAME AND
GAME.
IT'S FRESH IN YOUR MIND.
>> Dave: LOTS OF TIME.
ON THE BREAKOUT.
COMES
THERE H SHOT HERE
OF HOW MANY PLAYERS ARE ON THE
ICE.
NOW LOOK TO THE OTHER
BRANNST BERNARD-DOCKER.
KREBS FINDS UP IN THE
FINAL 50 LATE OFF THE STICK OF X